all right welcome to hannity this busy
friday news night tonight once again we
are tracking multiple developing stories
in moments we will have more from the
democrats
again their rush to judgment their snap
impeachment their latest political
charade
we are now learning more about one of
the rioters who was just arrested
a left-wing activist who recently
appeared get this on fake news cnn how
appropriate right
and in just a moment we'll have a
breaking news development from the
biggest abuse of power corruption
scandal in american history again the
media mob nowhere to be found they were
pushing conspiracy theories and lies
and yet another promise fulfilled by the
president
what is now a trove of documents
surrounding the russia hoax
are now in the process of being
declassified
and are expected to be released at any
moment coming up john solomon will be
here with an exclusive preview
first only hours ago the senate
judiciary committee
they released their own set of documents
including transcripts from
interviews conducted during the
committee's investigation
into crossfire hurricane remember
crossfire hurricane
fbi code name given to comey's probe
into the trump-russia collusion hoax he
signed three of the four fisa
application warrants based on the dirty
dossier
and according to the transcripts one
federal agent told the u.s
senate that without a doubt christopher
steele's material
was politically motivated the agent said
quote it was completely obvious that
this information intended to be used
by one of the parties against the other
wow
that didn't stop the fbi agents from
then coordinating with steel
even after steel was removed as an
official fbi
source and according to this transcript
they continue to communicate with steele
by using doj official bruce ohr as an
intermediary
remember bruce ohr's wife nelly she
worked for fusion gps
yeah where steele worked with the
dossier